[Music]
this episode and others like it are made
possible by the generous support of my
patrons on patreon if you'd like to help
support my channel and get early access
to every video consider becoming a
patron at patreon.com second thought
let's get this straight
how to be at the united states reviewed
by the rest of the world
as interfering with the elections
directly of other countries
and everybody knew it
what would it be like if we engage in
activities
that he is engaged in
it diminishes the standing of a country
that is desperately trying to make sure
it maintains its standing as a major
world power
that's part of what makes us special as
americans unlike the old
empires
we don't make these sacrifices for
territory or for resources
we do it because it's right
it's funny the countries which have
spent the greatest amount of time
enslaving invading overthrowing and
exploiting the rest of the world are for
some reason seen as the torchbearers of
civilization today while many powerful
and wealthy nations engage in this sort
of behavior none hold a candle to the
united states in this episode we're
going to debunk the myth that the us
does not interfere in foreign affairs
and take a brief look at the mountains
of evidence that show contrary to what
u.s leaders would have you believe this
country is the most meddlesome in the
world to give some context for biden's
speech at the beginning of the video he
was talking about russia's alleged
attempts to meddle in u.s elections
while much of the russia fear-mongering
was and is an attempt to deflect blame
for america's own problems we need to
realize that most strong nations are
always messing with their peers and
competitors to their own advantage
espionage or throwing a wrench in
foreign affairs is not some fringe
approach to global geopolitical
jockeying it has for a very long time
been a fairly common method of one
nation trying to get ahead of others
russia does it the us does it france the
uk you name it it's immature and a
historical to throw a fit about other
nations meddling when your own nation is
doing the same thing it's especially
ridiculous if you're the president of
the united states the nation guilty of
the most foreign interventions by far
we'll start with u.s interference in
elections specifically
well as special counsel robert mueller
continues his probe into russian
meddling into into the 2016 election we
take a look back at washington's record
of meddling in elections across the
globe by one count the united states has
interfered in more than 80 foreign
elections between 1946 and 2000 and that
doesn't count u.s backed coups and
invasions
since the end of world war ii the united
states has tried to influence the
outcome of elections in italy iran japan
brazil costa rica chile uruguay italy
again el salvador panama nicaragua
ukraine russia mongolia el salvador
again and palestine to name just a few
each of these instances failed to make
the kind of news that russian meddling
is making today i guess it's different
when you're on the receiving end and you
don't have to take my word for it here's
former cia director james woolsey openly
admitting our efforts to undermine the
democratic process in order to further
u.s interests
have we ever tried to meddle in other
countries elections
oh probably but
it was for the good of the system in
order to avoid the communists from
taking over for example in europe
in 47 48 49 the greeks and the italians
we don't do that now though we don't
mess around in other people's elections
only for a very good you know do that do
a vine video on those former cia drugs
only for a very good cause of the
interest of democracy thanks for being
here you'll notice that he can't even
say we're no longer meddling in foreign
elections this should be obvious to
anyone keeping up with current events
but it's pretty damning to hear it
directly from the organization
responsible for many of these crimes
you'll also note that woolsey made sure
to say that we only mettle for very good
reasons and in the interest of democracy
now it was my understanding that the
democratic process meant the people of
their respective nations had the right
to make their voices heard at the ballot
box free from coercion or interference
if that's the case then the united
states government's definition must be
something entirely different in what
world is it in the interest of democracy
to have a foreign intelligence agency
undermining elections to influence the
result that's like burning a house down
and saying you're doing it to prevent
fires
okay so wait if the united states isn't
actually defending democracy around the
world if we're actively undermining the
democratic process why are we doing it
what's the real reason
well if you take a look at the history
of u.s activity abroad it shouldn't be
hard to find the answer nearly every
single foreign intervention by the
united states with very few exceptions
has been in the interest of acquiring
resources expanding our imperial reach
and establishing new military footholds
or overthrowing governments that refuse
to bend the need to us superiority and
installing puppet regimes more agreeable
to us goals in the region this may sound
uncharitable but it's objectively true
we have libraries worth of evidence of
the imperialist crimes of the united
states i've left some examples in the
description
it's not random either the capitalist
powers especially the us have very
specific targets they try to sabotage
what kind of governments does the us try
to undermine it is always those that
have implemented or are beginning to
implement left-wing economic policies
the united states corporate-controlled
government understands that humane
common-sense worker-centric policies are
incredibly appealing to the average
person including americans u.s
leadership does not want to run the risk
of a successful left-wing economy
growing large enough to offer the world
an alternative to destructive genocidal
capitalism but trying to influence the
outcome of elections will only get you
so far if you really want to throw a
wrench in things you need to take a more
aggressive approach
this is where the us really shines
you've probably seen this infographic
floating around online it's a little
outdated at this point and doesn't even
include all the us's interventions but
the fact that the united states the
supposed defender of freedom and
democracy has engaged in at least 56
military interventions in latin america
since 1890 is insane
when casting doubt on an election
outcome just isn't enough the imperial
powers have some other tricks up their
sleeve the favorites of the united
states are fomenting coups funding
right-wing death squads and sending in
the cia or paramilitary groups to cause
as much chaos and disarray as possible
the list is far too long to cover in
depth but let's take a look at just a
couple of the more well-known examples
we'll start with chile
tuesday september the 11th
out of an early autumn sky
two jets launch a deadly attack on a
potent symbol of democracy and freedom
in a nation's capital
the result is fire suicide and
ultimately the death or disappearance of
over 3 000 people
shock waves are felt around the world
this is the story of one day in
september
since the early 1930s chile had been a
shining example of democracy and
political stability in latin america all
of that came to a screeching halt in
september of 1973. salvador allende a
physician and socialist politician had
been elected president in september of
1970 making him the first marxist to
hold the office of president in a latin
american liberal democracy the united
states didn't like that allende had
served his country in various government
positions for over 40 years before
ascending to the presidency and as
president his platform included
nationalizing key industries improving
and expanding education and improving
the living conditions of the working
class
these common-sense policies made him
quite popular among the chilean people
though decidedly less popular with the
right-wing parties that controlled other
parts of the government and even less
popular with the united states which had
begun actively plotting to overthrow the
democratically elected chilean president
and install a puppet dictator these
plans came to fruition on september 11
1973. the chilean military supported and
advised by the cia laid siege to the
presidential palace ayende vowed he
would not leave and instead broadcast
what would become his final speech to
his fellow chileans an inspiring call to
never give up and look towards a
brighter future free from oppression
from inside the palace a yendi refused
to leave
true to his promise not to surrender the
government for which the ordinary people
of chile had voted
he broadcast this last message
then he shot himself
foreign
took his own life rather than let the
us-backed coupe plotters capture him
after the military seized power general
augusto pinochet established a military
dictatorship which would remain in place
until 1990 crippling the chilean economy
and destroying all the progress made by
allende's socialist initiatives you've
probably seen right wingers make
references to pushing their political
opponents out of helicopters they're
referring to chile under pinochet it was
common during that bloody period for the
military to kidnap dissidents take them
up in helicopters and throw them out
typically over the water and usually
with their stomachs cut open so that
their bodies would sink at pinochet's
direction thousands of chileans were
tortured executed or disappeared all of
this was the result of the united states
and their genocidal commitment to
ensuring no economic system could ever
offer an alternative to capitalism
let's look at another example nicaragua
after the revolution during which the
socialist sandinistas overthrew the
samosa dictatorship in 1979 the united
states once again set its sights on
latin america the u.s had originally
intended to work out some kind of
agreement with nicaragua but when the
country chose to side with the global
socialist movement and work with cuba
and the soviet union instead the u.s
quickly changed its approach as with
chile u.s leadership was completely
unwilling to allow a budding left-wing
economy to grow to eventually challenge
the myth of capitalist superiority they
feared a socialist movement a genuinely
democratic movement unlike the facade of
democracy we have in the u.s would
inspire revolutions throughout latin
america in december of 1981 reagan
authorized covert operations in
nicaragua
these operations would eventually
include funding arming and training what
were called the contras groups dedicated
to overthrowing the new government among
the equipment provided by the cia were
instruments of torture and assassination
one of the more egregious actions that
earned the united states a slap on the
wrist for violation of international law
was the cia's production and
distribution of a manual titled
psychological operations in guerrilla
warfare this guidebook which the cia
distributed to their loyal right-wing
death squads encouraged the
assassination of certain targets
including non-military personnel like
judges police officers and government
officials it also encouraged the
inciting of riots and shootings which
would result in the death of selected
members of the contras themselves with
the aim of turning them into martyrs and
thereby building support for the contra
cause the united states would continue
to sow chaos in nicaragua for years
amassing a death toll of over 50 000
people and destroying the popular
democratic movement these are just two
examples from one region in latin
america alone the united states has
launched at least 56 military
interventions in recent memory and don't
make the mistake of assuming that's all
in the past it still happens the
venezuelan police captured a group of
american coop plotters just last year
and as we speak we're witnessing a surge
of right-wing opposition to the
democratic election of socialist
candidate pedro castillo in peru it is
absolutely guaranteed those factions are
working with u.s intelligence agencies
to undermine the democratic process and
prevent socialism from gaining any
ground
latin america represents the front lines
in the fight to throw off the yoke of
capitalism and build a brighter freer
future without the oppression of the
united states or the other imperialist
powers it is essential that western
socialists support these struggles for
self-determination
but latin america isn't the only target
we've also seen decades of coups and
attempted nation-building by the u.s in
the middle east and in asia there's a
reason the united states is running 24 7
propaganda operations and has over 400
military bases surrounding china a
country that routinely supports growing
socialist movements in other countries
so when u.s officials claim that we
don't meddle in foreign elections that
we do what we do for the sake of
defending democracy and freedom
understand that they're lying to you and
they know it the united states does not
defend democracy abroad we don't even
have real democracy at home american
leadership has lied about socialism for
over a century and if you don't believe
me read the cia's own words on stalin
saying that the western conception of
communism is wrong and that the soviet
union did indeed have collective
leadership as opposed to the strongman
dictator myth that american leadership
pedals to this day all of this
information is out in the open you can
find it just by searching a few keywords
online
the fact that the president of the
united states can address the american
people and brazenly claim that this
country does not meddle in foreign
affairs should be insulting to you every
u.s administration is counting on the
fact that the american citizens will
never take the time to educate
themselves and deconstruct the
imperialist propaganda prove them wrong
read non-western sources talk to people
from different countries learn actual
history the internet makes all of this
easier than it's ever been
moving the needle away from genocidal
imperialism and capitalist domination
and towards egalitarian socialism and
true democracy will be a challenge it
will require average people going out of
their way to correct false narratives to
educate themselves and those in their
circle but if we want to ensure a
livable future if we want our children
and grandchildren to actually experience
freedom and democracy we have to start
today
i mentioned at the beginning of this
video that this kind of content is made
possible by my patrons on patreon when i
decided to make the shift from general
interest stuff to more radical political
content i knew i ran the risk of syncing
my channel and losing my ad revenue and
sponsors these days it's pretty hard to
get a sponsor on my videos i have one
reliable one and they're great but for
the most part i'm having to rely on the
generous support of viewers like you if
you appreciate the work i'm doing and
you're able to chip in even a dollar a
month i would greatly appreciate the
support as a little show of that
appreciation every patron regardless of
donation amount gets early access to
every video as well as access to our
patrons only discord server it's a great
place to hang out chat with other
like-minded people or learn about
socialist theory in our book club i'm
also pretty active in the server so
you're always welcome to ping me to ask
a question or just say hi you can find
my patreon join our growing discord
server and get early access to every
video at patreon.com second thought if
you enjoyed this video consider dropping
a like if you hated it a thumbs down you
can check out my previous videos by
clicking the links on your screen thanks
for watching and i'll see you next week
[Music]
you